combien de marche
avez vous monté depuis ce matin
réfléchissez bien par marche je ne parle
pas seulement de calais je parle de
toutes les petites marches du quotidien
j'imagine que vous êtes sorti de chez
vous vous avez pris les transports pour
aller au bureau puis vous êtes allés
déjeuner peut-être dans un bistrot et
vous avez repris les transports pour
venir jusqu'ici
combien de marche moi c'est sûr 0 mais
vous ne savez pas c'est normal vous
savez marché mais vous ne voyez pas les
marches pour vous une marche c'est
tellement naturel totalement
inconscients de la même manière vous
n'avez sûrement pas remarqué les neuf
marches devant la porte d'entrée ici le
problème c'est que cette marche qui est
si facile et si naturel pour vous cloue
quelqu'un comme moi sur le trottoir à la
porte
voire pire chez moi les marches sont
partout salut de portes dit même
trottoir voiture transports bureaux
restaurants boutiques
quand on ne peut pas monter une marche
on ne va pas très long je ne sais pas si
vous avez aimé
à paris le métro est totalement
inaccessible aux personnes en fauteuil
pourtant vous êtes nombreux ici à
utiliser tous les jours
l'un c'est absolument impossible pour
moi pas d'ascenseur sauf sur l'a14 mais
pour les 13 autres lignes assis sur la
une
il ya et stations accessibles c'est
super ça veut dire qu'on peut entrer
dans le métro ne pas partir
mais rassurez vous on a fait une loi
tous les lieux recevant du public doit
faire des travaux pour permettre à tous
d'y accéder entre nous ça n'arrivera
jamais trop cher trop compliqué alors
ont repoussé échéance depuis plus de 15
ans babeau comme on dit c'est
l'intention qui compte
donc on doit tous nommés les obstacles
mais encore faut-il avoir conscience des
obstacles
combien de marche vous avez monté déjà
c'est ce que j'appelle l'effet boîte de
nuit les boîtes de nuit c'est super mais
comme ça fait du bruit on les enterre
donc il y à des marches en même temps ça
fait plutôt joli regardez à cannes
chaque année je me demande comment je
ferais si je devais monter les marches
le problème c'est qu'on met démarches
pour faire joli sans penser aux
conséquences
et quand on demande aux gérants des
boîtes de nuit pourquoi elles ne sont
pas accessibles
il vous répondre ça c'est pas la peine
j'ai jamais vu personne en fauteuil dans
ma boîte vu la tonne de marge que tu as
à l'entrée en même temps ça risque pas
d'arriver quand je me renseigne pour
savoir si un lieu accessible
ça ne manque jamais on répond toujours
la même chose j'ai un doute mais au pire
c'est pas grave on vous portera sauf
qu'on ne te panneau portait donc on fait
comment les gens s'arrangent
parce que ça les arrange mais en
fauteuil
ça roule ça ne vole pas quand on ne peut
ne pas prendre les transports ou entrer
dans une boutique
c'est très difficile de se considérer
comme quelqu'un de libre nous ne sommes
pas égaux devant la marche en fait
cette petite marche c'est quasiment la
seule différence entre nous celle qui me
vaut d'être catégorisé en valide et vous
banide
au fait vous connaissez la définition du
handicap
à l'origine c'est plutôt rigolo ça vient
du monde du sport et plus
particulièrement du hippisme
le handicap
c'était le fait de vouloir donner autant
de chance à tous en imposant des
difficultés supplémentaires aux
meilleurs
cette blague non mais le handicap c'est
surtout une leçon sociale regardons ce
que dit le ms un peu plus d'actualité
c'est clair non moi quand même reprend
le handicap n'est pas simplement un
problème de santé
il s'agit d'un phénomène complexe
desjardins d'accord j'ai un problème
mais j'en ai pas tout en plus parce que
c'est vachement compliqué qui découlent
de l'interaction entre les
caractérisques corporelle d'une personne
et les caractéristiques de la société où
elle vit ça c'est super important
ça veut dire qu'à partir du moment où on
crée un monde sans marche
je ne suis plus vraiment handicapé et si
on lit la fin de la définition pour
surmonter les difficultés auxquelles les
personnes handicapées sont confrontés
les interventions destinées à lever les
obstacles environnementaux et sociaux
sont nécessaires donc arrêtons de faire
comme si les marches n'existait pas
là je vous parle de marche parce que
c'est mon obstacle mais le handicap ce
n'est pas que des gens en fauteuil sera
important de ne pas l'oublier
vous l'avez bien définition est
tellement vague ça ne veut rien dire
handicap moteur handicap mental handicap
syfy handicap sont sans réelle maladie
invalidante
en vrai fourre tout quel est le point
commun entre un déficient intellectuel
un maniaco dépressif un mal voyant un
dyslexique et quelqu'un comme moi
ballons jaunes
quel est le point commun entre vous et
moi beaucoup de choses c'est vraiment
l'environnement qui rend les gens
handicapés ont les surprotège on les
infantilise on les rend assisté est
persuadé du fait qu'ils ne sont pas
comme vous mais surtout que vous êtes
différent d'eux et comme on n'aime pas
trop ce qui est différent on veut tous
se protéger alors on place les enfants
handicapés dans des centres spécialisés
où ils n'ont que des amis handicapés
on met à leur disposition de transports
spécialisés et on les fait travailler
dans des milieux protégés
c'est là toute la valeur sociale du
handicap ou plutôt la non valeur le
poids est forcément ça fait peur mais je
vous rassure vous n'êtes pas les seuls à
avoir peur pendant longtemps j'ai été en
dix femmes je détestais tous qui parlait
de handicap et j'étais très mal à l'aise
quand je croisais une personne
handicapée dans la rue elle me dérange
et elle me renvoyer une image de moi que
je n'ai pas et que je n'ai pas du tout
envie d'avoir ma chance c'est d'avoir
grandi dans un environnement valide
entouré de gens valides et mon combat
c'est d'aller partout j'ai envie d'aller
surtout si on y attend pas du coup j'ai
créé ma boîte je ne vous cache pas qu'au
début c'était pas gagné comme tout
entrepreneur
j'ai commencé par ouvrir un compte
bancaire pour immatriculer ma société
est là
gros gros problème de crédibilité
déjà on n'est pas habitués à voir une
personne handicapée travailler mais
alors monté sa boîte
on n'y pense pas on nage en plein délire
mon banquier ne m'a pas crue n'est pas
cru du tout il a pensé que je ne
trouvais que je voulais ouvrir un compte
normal d'un conte pro jamais de la vie
je divague et ce ne serait pas arrivé
dans une banque en ligne
car sur internet le handicap n'existe
pas on ne voit même pas le fauteuil on
part du principe que les gens par défaut
sont capables c'est ce qui m'a plu dans
le monde des start up
les entrepreneurs n'ont qu'une ambition
changer le monde créer un monde meilleur
et quand je voulais rencontrer jean
super enthousiaste c'est moderne en
entrepreneur en fauteuil
ça casse les codes c'est inspirant on
aime ça sauf que paradoxalement ils sont
installés dans le quartier le plus
d'inaccessible de paris dans le marais
est là va évidemment pas d'escalier et
de marche partout une fois de plus on
cherche des solutions bancales pour
essayer de me faire accéder et une fois
de plus on finit souvent sur un trottoir
au café du coin ou à changer le monde
sur skype à distance sur internet
il n'y a pas de marche c'est accessible
à tous tout le monde se côtoie sens je
n'ai et pour toutes ces personnes qui
ont tant de mal à sortir de chez elle on
peut tous faire livrer sans avoir à
affronter les obstacles dehors allez au
restaurant en un clic
même visité des musées c'est sûr c'est
bien
mais est ce vraiment la solution est ce
que c'est vraiment ça la vie et surtout
est-ce que c'est vraiment ça qui va
permettre la réconciliation de deux
mondes en vase clos
j'ai voulu créer mon entreprise pour
permettre aux personnes à mobilité
réduite de sortir de chez elles de
pouvoir se déplacer d'arrêter de
renoncer du coup j'ai créé le premier
site de voiture aménagée pour les
personnes en fauteuil à la location
entre particuliers
les propriétaires d'une voiture aménagée
qui ne s'en sortent pas tous les jours
peuvent la louer directement une
personne en fauteuil qui en a besoin
concrètement ça permet de trouver des
voitures aménagé par tous pour beaucoup
moins cher
l'économie collaborative la location
soin particulier ça n'a rien de nouveau
dans des start up
sauf qu'aucune ne s'était intéressé
jusqu'ici à la problématique du handicap
et de la mobilité le monde les start up
et quasiment vierge des problématiques
de handicap
peut-être parce que cette notion n'a pas
vraiment de réalité tangible
surtout sur internet mais aussi et
surtout parce qu'on est terriblement
habitués à considérer que le handicap
doit être pris en charge par les
associations ou par les pouvoirs publics
c'est toujours la même question de nos
valeurs on ne doit pas parler d'argent
quand on parle de handicap et le fait
que je me sois attaqué à une
problématique traditionnellement présent
charge de manière subventionné ça met
mal à l'aise beaucoup de personnes
seulement son argent c'est très
difficile de fournir un service de
qualité
avec cette plateforme on mutualisent
plus de 100000 véhicules et en même
temps on divise les coups par deux parce
que plus la peine d'acheter des voitures
et devait faire aménager
on se repose sur le parc existant et
surtout on permet à des personnes de ne
plus être assistés
prise en charge mais de devenir acteur
solidaire le fait d'en déduire une
notion d'argent aussi minimes
soient-elles
c'est un dur de la valeur les personnes
en situation de handicap sont capables
de créer de la valeur et de la richesse
et c'est à nous le prouver
j'invite toutes les personnes comme moi
en situation de handicap à relever ce
défi
alors ne seront plus un poids pour la
société pour vous tous ici
mais relever ce défi c'est une aventure
collective une fois de plus
collaborative nous devons créer cette
valeur tous ensemble avec vous à vous de
prendre conscience des obstacles que
vous avez oublié et banalisé pour nous
offrir un environnement accessible et
chaleureux alors nous serons vous et moi
du même monde et commençons dès
aujourd'hui vous ne savez pas par quoi
commencer par une chose toute simple
arrêtez de faire comme si les marches
n'existait pas